The intersection of A and B contain the elements 5 and 15. The union of A and B
contain the elements 1, 2, 5, 8, 9, 12, 15, 17 and 18. How do we get that the
intersection of A and B just contains 5 and 15? We know that intersection means
and. So, we have to find the numbers that are in set A and in set B. Well,
there's only two numbers that are in both sets. Here, 5 is in both sets, and 15
is in both sets. And those are the only two numbers that are in both sets. So,
the intersection of A and B is 5 and 15. When I want to find the union of two
sets, I know that union means or.
So, I want all of the elements that are in set A or in set B, which basically
means all of the elements in both sets. So, I have 1, 2, 5. Now, even though
five is in both sets, we only write it one time. And then I have 8, 9, 12, and
again 15 is in both sets, but we only write it once. And then I have 17, and I
have 18.